to present the awards for cinematography
the Academy selected two of the cameras
favorite subjects miss Doris Day and mr.
Rock Hudson
the nominees for best achievement in
cinematography black-and-white are Sam
Levitt for the Defiant ones Daniel L fat
for desire under the Elms Lionel Lyndon
for I want to live Charles Lang jr. for
separate tables Joe McDonald for the
Young Lions and the winner is Sam Sam
Levitt is mr. John Hall
thank you very much on behalf of Sam
Leavitt who is unfortunately not here
but he is working he's in Minnesota he
told me to come here and get this for
him if he got it this is the closest
I'll ever come to an Oscar
I want to thank you I want to thank mr.
Kramer on behalf of mr. Levitt and his
very fine crew and United office thank
you very much
the nominees for best color
cinematography are Harry straddling
senior for Auntie Mame William Daniels
for Cat on a Hot Tin Roof
Joseph Rotenberg for Gigi James Wong
Howe for the old man in the sea and Leon
Sam Roy for South Pacific
the winner is Joseph trottenberg who's
easy